i
am a mental health nurse now required to
attend healing racial trauma training
oh presenter's website full of crt lingo
critical race theory lingo sent letter
to my human resources person with help
from james lindsay website
new discourses i'm now nervous in ann
arbor
thoughts love you too
um i'll bet ann arbor's gone a bit woke
that's where we did our graduate work
and it was a lovely lovely town but cold
at some times of the year but
hot at other times of year yeah i could
deal with the hot more easily
um but yeah i'll bet that r1 university
in a relatively small town with a lot of
culture and a fair bit of federal money
coming in from grants
has made it pretty woke and i
feel your pain um
you don't say what has happened you know
maybe you've just sent the letter to the
to hr uh and you don't you don't have a
response yet
i don't know i don't know what to say
more than that i mean unfortunately i
think there is nothing to say
it's dangerous i hope it goes well i do
think we need to develop
a modality as we started to on our last
podcast getting people to write down
their faulty claims so that they are
checkable in the future and that they
cannot escape them
is one feature of that landscape in this
case
if it's a training you can't you can't
ask the person
doing the training that one's applicable
here but yeah what
would i do here i think
i would be trying to introduce the idea
that that solution you are proposing is
a threat
to something that is serving everyone in
other words
there's a problem to be solved the
solution you are proposing to it
threatens to destroy
much more than you realize is in its
scope
and i don't know frankly i don't think
an individual is going to be
in general in any position at all to do
that in a context
like the one you described but somehow
to the extent that we
as a larger group of people talking
about this can
lodge in the discussion um
and well in fact i was talking to
douglas murray
in my podcast with him several days ago
and he pointed out uh so my claim to him
was that the woke revolution
is actually going to destroy we've got a
system that fails to meet
its objective there's a gap between what
it does and what it aspires to do
but that the challenge to the
system as a whole is going to evaporate
the well-being that the system
is delivering and distributing yes
unfairly but distributing to everybody
and what douglas said that i was unaware
of he said
this is reminiscent of kant's point
about the bird that thinks
that the air which is causing
drag drag yes is the obstacle to it
flying really fast and if only the air
could be done away with it would be that
much speedier when in fact wouldn't that
be the life
yeah when it can't fly at all without
the air so
to the extent that we can start making
this point to people look you have no
idea what you are threatening yes there
are real problems with
how well-being and opportunity are
distributed there just are
um but you're going to kill the thing
that makes
well-being exist at all and
it's not going to be good for anybody
including the people that you think
you're helping
um so i don't know that we can make that
resonate but it's the kind of thing
one person's saying it isn't going to be
enough saying it multiple times isn't
going to be enough
but to the extent that that message
begins to come from different places
and it causes some who are on this
bandwagon to think oh
wait a second i could i could evaporate
the very thing that i'm trying to see
distributed
more fairly yeah i'm trying to enhance
mental health for instance
across people and attending
a healing racial trauma training having
having to
incorporate such thinking into the rest
of what i do
may actually cause everything to decline
in quality
yes i feel certain it absolutely will
but you obviously have to couch things
more gently for an audience that
can't hear it yeah and i would also just
add this whole
idea of healing racial trauma
it sounds so right and it is so
backwards because the fact is what you
actually need
is opportunity if you've been frozen out
of opportunity what you need
is opportunity and the tools to make use
of it and
my experience dealing with people all
over the world
is as soon as you have that
opportunity and the tools to utilize it
the trauma scars over
right it's not like it's gone it's not
like the history evaporates but the
point is it is not an obstacle to
day-to-day
well-being functioning happiness any of
those things as soon as the problem
is addressed well i mean this is an
analogy that you've used under
a lot of um in a lot of circumstances
here but
it really is so apt is that
um you don't we will all experience
injury in life some of it literal some
of it metaphorical
and at first it creates wounds and
long term short as short term as
possible
we hope that it scars over such that the
wounds are a thing of the past without
ever pretending that the injury did not
happen
you retain the scar you don't retain the
wound and that so much
of the modern ideology is about picking
and picking and picking and picking and
making sure that you never scar over so
there was always exposed wound to
display to people
and to announce about how how awful you
have it and
how it can never be made right and that
is in part
a result of the constant picking at it
yes
keeping the wound open because the wound
is your entitlement
to you know to be given something yeah
and like you know what the injury
happened what you know whatever in some
cases people are just making [ __ ] up
right but presume that there's something
real here the injury happened
the scar can still be your indicator of
injury but also allow you to move
forward
and a wound specifically keeps you mired
in the past and keeps you from
from becoming anything better and you
know part of part of it is exactly what
we're talking about in the first hour
you know your your your pessimism
about about you know being able to fix
whole swathes of the population
is i i think in part based on um
you you seeing that so many people are
busy picking at their wounds
uh and uh and sure
100 i know it's not entirely i know
there's another big part of it which is
that they you know they
they arrive you are arguing
uh without uh an ability to
full without an ability to win in a
meritocracy yeah without tools
um but certainly it only makes it worse
if you if what is being told
to them and this is being this is
happening in the k-12 schools and higher
ed so this is happening for people
across
all levels where they still could
generate a toolkit with which to
actually move forward with
um creativity and analysis and
productivity
and if what they're being told instead
is
keep focusing on your wounds and the
wounds of others and how wounded they
are compared to you
uh well no one's going to win ultimately
except the very few people who are in
charge of
uh i don't know wound defining yeah i
would say that in
you know if we go back to the question
of
can we agree on a collective objective
that's
that uh replaces the you know the left
right oscillation
as a control mechanism the point is look
you have an
obligation to make yourself as capable
as possible
right to deal to scar over rather than
keep your runes open
having done that we have an obligation
to make the system
fair right to the extent of the system
isn't fair
we have work to do but you also have
work to do and it is the partnership
between those things you make yourself
as capable as possible
yep we'll make the system fair you know
as quickly as possible
that's the shared objective and it
doesn't involve
i'm not going to make myself capable at
all because the reason i'm not capable
is unfairness
and you know take care of me like that's
just not a
stable long-term pattern
[Music]
you